hi guys welcome to Friday re the video
in which I show you things I did all
week I know what you're probably
thinking
who's this pretentious bag of dicks
sitting in this picturesque location
well didn't start that way this week
started off in New York
and then this happened I just got home
and I'm really sweaty and gross it
smells weird in my place but I just got
a package um from my editor then pretty
sure is the final final book I'm gonna
open it right now I'm gonna change a
one-handed can't foresee a better way
don't hurt that innards oh thank god
there's another package within this
package grace it's a book can you
believe it and it's the actual book it's
the real look it's got a bet
this is the real thing it's got a price
tag on it I'm gonna take a second and
figure out what the weird smell is in
the house but just also remind you to go
to Grace's book like chrome and
pre-order your book because they're
coming out in less than a month and the
graces guy contests still going on
there's over 600 prizes and sweepstakes
ten winners announced every week so make
sure you do that cool
don't just stare back at me like you're
a book don't forget about that thing
self
remember when you film that thing whoa
talk about mental pain I mean the humans
it's a video but do whatever or stare
Otan and she's definitely not gonna look
at you maimry came over to do some
business mm-hmm and brought our business
associate with us well we don't make a
big decision unless she's here let's the
talk about Kylie she's wearing either a
Parisian scarf okay a little neck brace
Oh both it's like if we want her to be
respected nots in front to get some
insurance money on the back wow that's a
memory we're in some harsh lighting
we're headed to see two of my favorite
content creators rhett and Link why did
I refer to them so professionally like
content creators and human beings in
general we're gonna go record a podcast
with them I don't know if you guys know
this but I got to be their very first
guest on their very first podcast last
year and so we're doing a follow-up
episode of what's happened this past
year
Jemaine Trista and also puts it live on
guard because I think I got lucky being
the first guest on their podcast cuz
they were totally sure what it was yet
and it has since developed into this
really amazing podcast that ends up
getting like pretty deep and in
conversation with people and
unfortunately for me I didn't have to
get too deep with them now unfortunately
they know what they do
so we'll see it I don't like talking
about
oh they're actually the inspiration for
my podcast not too deep specifically
they are the inspiration are you taking
the photo of us before the podcast can I
use your video and it means you can use
it the video as your mirror and then see
this right here is it what is that it's
making choices unto itself
here's what's happening I'm guy okay I'm
so ready and we're going I'm a dit
through the podcast I'm alive oh the Sun
is awesome here cat damn it son I'm
going to reward myself by getting
through that super gas of buying buying
candles and then don't forget that
going to the airport this is very
throwback Thursday with other
appearances by
there you go that's a week I uh I'm on
the small vacation in honor of my
birthday and getting closer to death
their immortality someone's here
gotta go we're back I just want to
remind you guys that we are one week
closer to my book getting really is it
is very exciting so make sure that you
go to Grace's guide book comment
pre-order and enter the graces guide
tube stakes getting over 600 prizes away
it's really really an exciting thrilling
thing also Hannah Hannah mamrie and I
are going on our no filter show tour to
launch the book in October and a bunch
of the dates already sold out I believe
Denver and Chicago or the only shows
left that have some tickets available so
make sure that you go and get those
because it's going to a really really
brand-new fun show and I think those are
all the plugs yeah okay I don't have a
converter so those are all the plugs bye